Okay, I've got new book recommendations for
you today.
I used to do a once a week book recommendation
segment and it never did that well.
Um, I, it wasn't ever like a super popular
segment but the people that liked it really
liked it.
So after being on hiatus for a long period
of time, the book recommendation is a book.
Recommendations are back each uh, every couple
of weeks.
I'll recommend a couple of fiction books and
a couple of nonfiction books.
Remember that you can go to David pakman.com/recommendations
for my full list of recommendations and anything
you buy through the links at David pakman.com/recommendations
supports us.
Also, I have to be careful about how I word
this.
If you use those links.
And then you end up buying other things on
Amazon as well that will also support us.
I want to be careful that I'm in compliance
of the Amazon affiliate agreement.
I'm also going to make an effort to add some
commentary next to some of my recommendations
about what they are or why I like them or
whatever.
Okay, so let's start with the nonfiction books
today.
First one, the book is in order to live by
young me park.
This is another one of these somewhat controversial
books about someone who, uh, escaped North
Korea and like many of the books by North
Korean escapees.
There are questions about the accuracy of
some of the elements of the story, but nevertheless
a fascinating, fascinating read in order to
live by young me park reddit not long ago,
very quick read type of thing.
You can read on a flight or on a, on a relatively
short vacation.
Excellent, excellent book that I recommend
you check out.
And then there's a couple others at David
pakman.com/recommendations that are other
North Korean escapee stories.
Very, very interesting.
Okay.
Switching gears drastically to the healthcare
debate.
This is a book by the late Great UV Reinhardt
and the book is called priced out the economic
and ethical costs of American healthcare.
This is a book that is not one of these partisan
pop politics books that is either about single-payer
is socialism or you know, single payer is
the only way forward or whatever.
This is an academic book, but it's not diff.
It's not a difficult read and it's quite short.
In fact, it's only about if you don't include
the epilogue in the notes, it's under 140
pages.
Okay.
Very short book and it outlines the academic
economic mathematical case for getting definitely
off of the healthcare system.
We have really good ammunition to be armed
with if you are going to be talking about
healthcare with anybody.
Again, the book is priced out by you.
We Reinhart.
All right.
There's that.
Those are my two nonfiction recommendations.
Let me do two fiction recommendations.
The first one is, this is not a new book.
This is the trigger by Arthur C. Clark and
Michael Cube McDowell.
Maybe it's QB McDowell.
The concept here.
What year is this book from?
This book is from 1999.
It's a 20 year old book at this point.
The concept is a research lab comes across
a technology that would disable all firearms
when a device is placed in proximity.
It's almost like a mobile phone jammer except
it's a firearm jammer.
And at first it seems like this is going to
be a fantastic thing.
This is fiction by the way, just restating
that this is going to be a fantastic thing
for stopping gun violence.
It could be used by militaries to, uh, fight
wars without weapons being used.
The idea of it sounds fantastic, but then
Arthur C. Clark, as, as he is known to do,
gives us the other side of seemingly utopian,
uh, circumstances.
And there's not any political statement implicit
in what I'm saying.
This is just what the story is.
The trigger by Arthur C. Clark written along
with Michael Cube McDowell, excellent book,
20 years old, extremely still relevant today.
And lastly, another fiction book, the gone
world by Tom Sweater.
Lish.
This book was recommended to me by Joe Rogan's,
guests booker.
When I was on the Rogan program, we talked
about different Psi Phi that we had been reading
and Joe's guest booker got in touch with me
and said, hey, this is a really great book,
the gone world that you should check out.
And it is, it's a sort of time travel detective
novel and it is really, really great.
I ended up picking up some other books by
Tom Sweater lish after I read this one.
Um, the gone world, Tom Sweater lists all
of these recommendations@davidpakman.com slash
recommendations use the links there so that
everything you buy supports the David Pakman
show.
And I'll be adding and expanding that page
more going forward.